18 25 par deux ça fait 36 50 monsieur
s'est multipliée par 2 1
ah si je vous dis regardez
ça fait 18 francs 25 vous êtes touristes
les vacanciers les prix multiplié par
deux les étrangers par trois rep ah vous
n'êtes pas étranger non non c'est
simplement par deux donc de 18 25 on
passe à 36 50
on assomme les touristes et les les
étrangers maintenant on le dit c'est
nouveau ces nouveaux qu'on le dise
ah ouais mais maintenant moi j'ai décidé
de le dire parce qu on le fait sans le
dire je trouve pas cela honnête 6000
d'être honnête avec les gens pour la
somme 1 c'est vrai qu'on les vols ou au
moins leur dis maintenant c'est plus
régulier ou pensez pas
que ça tout le temps madame tout le
temps c'est depuis des plus que la côte
d'azur a du succès on vous vole on a
trois mois pour vous voler c'est pas
évident parce que à l'hiver vous venez
pas vous ici on n'a que trois mois pour
vous voler encore le mois de juin est
pas facile hein donc on a vraiment
juillet août pour vous tirer le maximum
de pognon quoi des convois des blaireaux
comme vous hop
on les presse comme des citrons en coin
c'est marrant
de 342 fort monsieur
114 x 3 parce que vous êtes touristes
j'ai de quoi vous êtes suisse allemand
les prix vont regarder monsieur les prix
sont multipliés par deux pour les
vacanciers 23 pour les étrangers
pourquoi ce qu'on est en saison on
assène de touristes ici monsieur on a
trois mois pour faire de l'argent vous
le savez bien comme on ne sait où on le
marque
donc ça fait 340 de francs
vous allez bien vous êtes volet sur la
côte d'azur monsieur vous le savez bien
monsieur la relaxe
bonjour
thomas marie vous mettez le doigt bien
profond et vous sentez après allez-y
quoi
rêver quand même
22 maraîchers quoi
affligeant ici on pèse ici on assomme on
se fait 90
micky
[Applaudissements]
oui ça fait trente francs il est
tellement
c'est multiplié par trois pour les
fridolins regardez c'est du vol
c'est de l'entubage on les en cubes
dont les en tube
les étrangers
en fait comme ça un tube et intubé et le
fait le tweet tweet la classe en tube
on le remet dans le cucquois
ok
voilà en fait on va la refaire traite à
savenay watts
choc non non non aïe stole you your
money et cosider côte d'azur et sur you
are blaireau
blaireau comme inside les
touristes
au match au match après match on vous a
bien [ __ ] et on vous remercie
bien sûr si les prix
ou socialement c'était trois fois le
prix
non 134 me fait pas cent balles et vous
ça vous est arrivé quand
on vous a également tué c'est pas du
tout au moins cher et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous
je m'étais un peu ce bleu